Android developer relations office hours
I'm Sparky from Munich Germany and I'm
joined by my colleagues a mat and Nick
and rich in London UK believe Rita my
sweet rissa we have his boots we have
Richard Theo of eq up dumb yeah my
conduct allergy counters Matt hi my
clothes today I've brought to you by the
dutch android usergroup always do is
someone else ran and the burn mg tug
steampunk on the back Nick brought to us
by Christmas I think yes by Christmas
Jim Christmas John hi I'm left five I
think man style eggless fails didn't say
met Matt and Irene passed Yuri are in
uniform today so someone had to be Matty
sorry Sparky we hijacked your beautiful
intro carry on that was that was far far
more interesting than just having me say
the usual thing hi anyway welcome
everybody this is Android developer
relations office hours we're here to
talk to you about anything related to
android application development usual
disclaimers apply which rich will be
happy to deliver basically we generally
restrict ourselves to SDK related issues
we don't talk about deep internals we
don't talk about unreleased products or
future plans but apart from that we're
happy to we're happy to basically you
know see what you're interested in talk
about what you're interested in I see
we're already joined in the Hangout by
several people I've got some folks who
have contributed questions in the
moderator hi Andrew hey and andrew has a
camera because his girlfriend wife is
watching x factor today hmm I can't see
myself though I'm not arresting I've
always had put youtube live stream on at
the same time works quite well if you
want to be ten seconds behind the rest
of us who's joined us on the far
right-hand side you'll see oh you'll see
they'll see guys last a year you'll see
he got me got the memo what the facial
hair yeah excellent so we have Alan Andy
Landrieu and you'll see all with us in
the Hangout
ah lately sporting wear with it good
quality camera from you yeah so so once
I tell you right everybody who was
something that you'd like to share with
us sir when I have you have a question
you wanna ask I've got something I'd
like to share go rich guy got used it
peeping from the UK specifically may
have noticed the t3 awards that went
past recently but the Nexus 7 tablet of
the year in fact was it gadget okay one
by best grazing meat out the ipad free
for tablet via and it won need the
overall the big category the gadget of
the year of the years the nexus 7 so
we've been having a few little parties
around the google office here to
celebrate that thank you very much to
teach me the little tablet that could oh
good indeed oh i have to say i mean it
is a marvelous device the Nexus 7 is my
basically might go to Android device I
mean I'll use my phone if I mountain
about because I don't generally bring
the tablet you know I I mean I'll even
bring my nexus 7 with me but it's in my
bag that the phone is in my pocket but
you know anywhere that I'm within range
of Wi-Fi the Nexus 7 is the device I
want to use okay agreed so developers
out there if you haven't started looking
at and your apps and you know if it's
running well if it's optimized for the
screen size and so on then now's a good
time yeah actually that rhymes that
reminds me isn't this week tablet week
shouldn't we be talking a whole lot
about tablets today do we go a bit early
last week hey okay music I will say
hello three times now lasted while you
guys were talking tablets I was out
there I was out there someone writing
deutschen einheit national holiday here
in Germany last we would jumping the gun
on tablets ah have you joined us today
because you've got some questions Leslie
we just come along to that to hang out
all right just to hang out and see
what's happening
welcome to the Hangout I see that also
Richard Thompson has just jumped on
hello Richard do you have anything you
want to talk about maybe you'll give you
a moment to go yourself establishing
internet chance ok so yeah this is a
point anyone in the Hangout can jump in
and ask a question before we hit the
moderator if anyone has anything they've
liked it yoshi is a showing off some
rather fancy i was at a series free but
i just wanted to show you kosovo I'm
sorry oh my son nice you've redecorated
your entire office to be Android examine
any cool nice dick should work like it I
like enhances your ability to do android
development and just a finish off we're
talking about tablets as well I think
the reason we declared this week talent
week is an arbitrary but it's also
mostly to celebrate the the new quality
guidelines we just released so it's a
series of kind of checks you can do to
make sure your application is going to
look Stella honor on larger devices so
hopefully you guys have all seen the
book post on Android developers blogspot
com and and seeing the check list and
come through that and have a look at
your apps and kind of scene do they make
good use of the white space are they
gonna scale are going to be available on
all devices which might have different
hardware configurations so it's kind of
what catalyzed this week's kind of feed
and Richard in the sidebar asks will
there be google TV quality guidelines
i'm gonna so we've got a load of
documentation on google TV design
guidelines over at developers.googl
compost tea v so yeah we've got a whole
load of stuff there are about making
these very cinematic and accounting for
the fact that you're not not really go
sort of the interactions more social
it's less of a one-to-one kind of thing
where people are usually using a
personal device so yeah go check that
out lots of in further so let's go check
this more of a kind of a document so
yeah
it's it's much more kind of along the
line to provide the new design stuff
that Android went through its it's more
of ya going through the different sort
of design pass you follow and other
aspects so has anyone on the in the
Hangout had a chance to have a look at
the tablet quality guidelines yet anyway
yeah yeah I've had a quick look through
him it looks cool it that useful is it
kind of thing you can you can see
yourself running through it it's
definitely the checklists definitely
something I could have run through with
every app because it's one of those
things you make assumptions about stuff
you get caught up in the design and then
you sit there anything don't I've
forgotten something fundamental so it's
really useful to especially that
checklist is really useful to have ya
find especially when you're developing
that you can't like develop on device
perhaps you might get into a single
device mindset where you're you know
going through debug cycle strike China I
get this piece of functionality working
and ship it and you sometimes don't
think about the breakfast stuff out
there so I think having this simple
checklist is really helpful so if you
guys see two and you have any feedback
or suggestions and ping android / thurs
or one of us and we can we can suggest
it everyone's getting their lower thirds
aren't forgiven us alone cool so is
there any live questions in the Hangout
or any other news that people want to
share before we kind of jump into the
moderator google TV game play is getting
native play yes welcome it look that
yeah I know it's been long as long
awaiting so yeah humana get native
patient finally went and buy movies and
play it straight to Google TV which is a
stick any changes for developers
anything like any different intent
filters or whatever they can use now
they can before and Canada not aware if
we get subscription billing with the
native place to us when that comes in
that's one that i think a lot of people
have been wanting for a little while so
yeah let's go grunts go in so you have
in am feeling right now and that's
perfect yeah so the mo we just got in
our billing no subscription so now
there's another launch last night in
fact they're free trials for
subscriptions i'm not that if you have a
subscription based product with the
years ago
free period kind of get the users hooked
listen checking on the sofa yeah so
Leslie asked a question on the spy Barry
says how many companies are using the
accessibility framework and I just sort
of snip aleera fight all the good ones
we nearly certainly have recommended
many times in the past that people
should at least put the content
description or other XML tags so
accessibility works but in terms of
using the entire accessibility framework
I don't have a metric on that know how
good he starts I do know the Wolfram
basic posted a good article and this
lately so if anyone reads grokking
android book blog it's great technical
blog and he recently did a very good
post occurring off how you would add
accessibility squatchier and that
article well the actual question is who
uses it for anything other than the
simple content description i mean we use
it extensively but the solution to how
powerful it really is too why keep drug
user hmm hey I think the Richer your
droid cognis this one oh excuse me go a
bit of a cough going on which one join
our drink on UK droid 22 UK yeah yeah
when we get there I'll give you a
insight to what we using a framework for
then you understand the question in
context to section it's a question which
context will come three weeks later but
yeah remind you any day I'll see if I
can take out any anything relevant for
you at that point as well they'll see
you at droidcon droit all UK i guess i
will be there as well yeah yeah I left a
great since he popping that and that's
up to be quite a few of us at roche are
you okay ok so we jump into the
moderator them what people
from like the next question yeah it's
our first question Chris and London is
there a reason why Google does not
release updates a new android versions
for all interested developers with nexus
7 a Galaxy Nexus devices right away
outside the long guy teen a cycle
without having to root through device
etc of course there's a reason I says it
would be a equals honest it would be
convenient to have an option of
developer options where you opt in to
the latest releases immediately rather
than waiting for your turn in the OTA
you know sort of phased rollout he says
yeah the only basically a developer
thing not a lot of people necessarily be
using it I actually think that's a great
idea and I liked it so much that I
opened a ticket in our in our issue
tracking system saying we should do this
so I I don't know that you would save a
lot of time because we don't really
waste a lot of time between you know
minute of code freeze and an OTA or
perhaps they may be the other way to
turn around or they say sometimes we
have a scheduled roughened deployment
and we code right up into the last
possible minute but plus it seriously
and we do a release if we know me
release the the recovery images right
they am so you could grab one of those
and flash yourself yeah oh as soon as it
hits ITA I'm pretty sure you can find
the link to down people get the units
and you don't need to read devices to
apply the official signed patches anyway
yeah it's chris this was this you chris
been there is a different Chris in
London oh man right now it's a bit more
than one good this is really love that
that happens fear Chris could be the
same ok no and of course there's
something like sometimes in the OTAs if
certain carriers require approval before
we apply patches to devices on my
network yep so advice to developers by
straight from play.google.com then you
don't have a diverter carrier in between
the OTA servers and ye or device he's
reference code uh Deborah um yeah yeah
yeah right but so sort of gist of my my
near the ticket that I opened was I I
suggested that
basically people who opt into this
should be able to jump to the head of
the queue in the face roll out rather
than you know waiting a few days that
way if you have an app that you know
maybe breaks on the new release you can
fix it ASAP rather than having to wait a
couple of days for your turn to get the
wrong the tripartite is wouldn't
everyone just go yeah i'm a developer
i'm just thinking that maybe it has to
be like in the pub site or so unless he
had to be a writer yeah yeah maybe
enroll a device through the developer
console or something like that yeah
that's gonna make you the play console
you just grab the fun run apply yeah if
you're a developer you're gonna be happy
enough doing though sure yes good ideas
one of the one otherwise i read that is
I they looking for a version between
releases so instead of waiting for of a
4 10 2 for 11 or for what 40 to 41
whether they're looking for something
between those two so that's what we did
for the first time we've jelly bean
right where we kind of had the Developer
Preview was out there for a while so you
could run it in the emulator and you
could get to know the new api's before
we went to a shipping run and work that
we for shipping on devices and the final
for an image right so i think that seems
to be the direction we're going I'd like
to assist it earlier if we can but you
know hmm I make these decisions
excellent okay well seeing as no one's
shouting to a jump to the next question
in the moderator we've got quite a few
to get through today oh it's dumb to the
next question mmm martin in brighton UK
says i know still a fair few months away
but Java 8 is on the horizon ok l I'll
give a very good answer to that y'all do
you want to want it to reprise for us
but you said sure basically Google is
you guys can't answer forward-looking
statements about product development but
one of the things with lambda
expressions is they need a change in the
virtual machine which came in in Java 7
and the dalvik virtual machine which
Android uses isn't equivalent to a java
virtual machine so you can't exactly say
that version of Java would be the same
as the bytecode available
version of the dalvik virtual machine so
there would probably be some work to
implement the functionality needed in
the dalvik virtual machine and as yet
that doesn't seem to have started to
being happen so it may happen but it's
not going to be for a while yet would be
pretty much the gist of the answer and
so so the short version of l's answer is
we're stealing we're still using java
1.6 is our target in an environment
target API level yeah pretty much what
else is in jail rate I mean I'm i miss
my london so much he said he's lenders a
lot what else is in eight there's not 17
right there's the diamond operator and
that's about it there's a lot of stuff
underneath the hood in seven there's one
of its dynamic invoke i think is the
bytecode that got introduced in java 7
which allows support for non java
languages to be called a mini and so on
exactly and it's that which is needed to
get lambda expression sorted as well so
i think a lot of the seven was
underneath the hood but it's also its
project coin so that was the whole
rebound for some the language justified
you can use switch light strings and
switch statements and stuff uh I mean
that was pushed back from 7th right
that's right a quorum d yeah I was
learning though because a lot of this
stuff like Landers can is often like
syntactical sugar isn't it it's often
stuff that might not have lower down
changes you might be like a preprocessor
step or something yeah I mean you can
achieve pretty much the same stuff with
using lists and of classes and
interfaces and that's the whole thing
that lambda expressions are being sort
of touted is replacing so there's no
absolute need for them but it it's one
of those things the less case you type
the happier developers are yeah let's go
to maintain less boilerplate easier to
read samples i think i think lunders a
great mayor he sees a lot but yeah i'd
like to see but no comment okay but I
don't know if awesome even when they're
coming
anyone for any more maybe in the chat
anything in the Google+ thread is that I
was all know you had it and now I feel
lost about it who's gonna get that first
I live in joining Google Plus I'll read
the next the next moderator question or
in l'ville great city where my previous
employer before Google had an
engineering team says have you heard of
Android annotations transfuse where's
dagger links included these are
annotation based compile time code
generation tools what do we think of
these I mentioned a few more rowboat
juice green ghoul or light I think
they're all perfectly fine the problem
basically is that every time you
introduce any kind of an abstraction
layer on top of an API it has the
potential to simplify matters as long as
you stay within it but when you when you
start integrating with the native other
features of the system sometimes it may
not integrate quite so smoothly so I
think they're all good ideas and I think
it's worth maybe worth a little bit of
time investigating and see if it works
for a use case I you know nothing
against them it's just a matter of is
the you know is the benefit that you've
gained from it worth the potential
inconvenience of fitting in it together
with the rest of the system under silly
goose parka one other thing I'd add to
that is and the reason I quite like the
annotation based ones is that tend to be
a compile-time and kind of stuff rather
than looking at runtime things like
looking at some like robo juice for
example which offers great functionality
but you're going to take a hit at
runtime using the reflection and so on
so I think that's one of the advantages
why I'd probably look into something
like that girl you know Android
annotations instead of the runtime ones
just because performance is such a
consideration or mobile my two cents
so any other comments in you see it
spark you mentioned that are employed
minute that's a runtime one so that's
run time on night meditations there's no
Vong called Greendale whereas that to
compile time but it's more work in it so
I'm just angry yeah Michael with these
exist they tend to be awesome when you
know how to use them like once you if
you're the developer of the the project
or doing any know it inside out it's
like look how easy it is I could just
like annotate this plantation in jizz a
billion things but I find them like
quite hard to learn but hard to pick up
unless you have that whole surface area
of knowledge about the what it is and I
find it can you be hard to debug
sometimes if you don't know when stop
especially with their dependency
injection if you don't know when stuff
is getting created instantiated where
it's coming from you know if you have a
distributing and someone's trying to
come in debug an issue then it can make
it more complicated so those are my only
concerns about around these frameworks
like if you have just a you know not
standard but you know an Android
developer he's coming in and might not
have experience and it could put them
off but otherwise I think if you have
tons of benefit yeah i'll also add just
for the point just for the sake of
adding it that green dao comes from
munich germany so Dominic Joey we've got
another question in the google plus
another question in the chat so Leslie
asks in the chat one will be able to add
our own channels may be referring to
instability you referring to google play
store yes even not it's fun ok now what
the probability google TV is that i'd
really like it to be able to control my
be plus boxer so for that i know the
frequencies i just want to add them but
without rooting the device of cognitive
journalist ok oh it's men so at the
moment you can't access the channel in
Europe we're working to bring that over
here because over in the US it's lazy to
get that data for the channels that you
have access to when you're still going
internationally it depends on which
country you're in there's a couple of
weird little quirks like people in
Germany they can change the order of
their channels which then upsets on data
etc so basically we're trying to find a
nice reliable way to actually give you
access to the information
but some of the stuff you've talking
about just then it rhymey of an API to
be announced at Google i/o called the
media devices API where you can then
essentially pretend to be a set-top box
or a sort of create a driver for an
actual set-top box and then you can
start communicating between the two so
that's going to come with a later
version of Google TV which we don't have
a date for yet but hopefully it won't be
too long so yeah sort of answers your
question I hope yeah sort of will the
Logitech get that upgrade though I
believe in tech review will I believe
you fingers crossed yes looks like oh so
in the in the comic Fred Yan is asking
about a layout guide for nexus 7 in
landscape and 10.1 tablets and that's it
what do you want to know i was thinking
use the same layout can i use the same
for tablet 10.1 and the nexus 7 the
answer is it depends it depends what
you're trying to lay out like this is
why we always say work with a designer
if you've kind of there is no magic Lord
that says layout that works on their
phone will work on a seven or working on
seven what works on several work on
tenders nothing like that it really
depends on your content so what I always
end up doing when I'm trying to like say
mock-up screens for Android design in
action you might start with the phone
layout and you might see what it looks
like in tete on 10 it might be to empty
it might be too dense and it really is
like a kind of a gut feeling thing you
end up kind of trying on different sized
layouts until you get the right amount
of spacing the right kind of density of
information so there's no magic law you
kind of have to look at it and decide
and in fact if you look at the Nexus 7
at the system apps that ship with it
some of them use the the UI which would
ship on a phone and some of them use the
tablet UI so people application for
example uses their tablet based you iron
it you know useless basically nicely we
like to column views and so on but some
of the applications like Google play
music for example uses the phone UI it's
a decision made by each kind of
application depending on the information
they're trying to show
and just how well it works in that given
amount of space so there is no answer to
this it to try it have a look to see if
it works if not you might need to hit
things might need to change something
you might need to add more space bigger
text sizes and like that so there's no
hard and fast rule and the nexus 7 falls
into the SW 600 DP bucket in the layouts
whoa so you're going to have your your
10 inch tablet you can put in the SW
720's your Nexus 7 in the SW six
hundreds and if you want the same
layouts you just get rid of the
assurance with 720 folder and just pick
up the same as the 7 inch but you can
very easily distinguish between phone 7
inch an hour and 10 inch tablets and
decide what goes in each one just by
testing it what's best I found it quite
interesting as well that the nexus 7
originally the launcher was locked in
portrait mode and the latest release of
jelly bean which is found about now
allows you to do the wonderful thing of
having the launcher in landscape as well
so i guess it's it really is yep that's
it oh it's just wanting to get it right
yeah so it just goes to show that
there's a lot of experimentation that
you need to do before you get things
that you enjoy well one thing that I've
noticed recently is I've been a little
bit surprised that even now we were what
a year and a half after after honeycomb
there a lot of apps especially games
just like even on a 10 inch tablet to
just scale up the phone UI and and I
think it's in particular for games it's
more of a problem even than some of the
others I mean yes they don't have the
problem with huge amounts of white space
because they're using OpenGL and scaling
everything proportionally but some of
these games use gestures where the
amount that you travel on screen matters
and it can actually be significantly
harder to play the same game on a tablet
because you have to move your finger
that much faster and the same Mr that
much further in the same amount of time
I'm thinking games like like flight
control or flick golf or something like
that where you train your you train your
muscles to work on a certain screen size
and then you switch to a tablet and all
of a sudden everything's different and
there's like a real fatigue factor that
comes into dragging those airplanes all
the way across the center screen it's
interesting in the tablet app quality
checklist three or four of the points
all go across the same same thing you
just rang in saying Sparky by using
fonts and touch targets and assets that
are designed for that kind of size of
screen so hopefully it's something that
the checklist will help reinforce for
people yeah the good news is it can be a
bit scary because you think the vet is
continuous like range of device sizes
out there so if you think about oh do I
have to hit my layouts and make a layout
that works great on a you know 4-inch
phone 5 inch phone a 7 inch tablet and
8.9 inch tablet like good thing about
this is like there's actually kind of a
discrete number of switching points at
the moment we kind of see a lot of the
stuff kind of setting around 4 7 and 10
is kind of like common places and that
the variations around there are not so
huge that you can use a layout that
works on like a 7-inch tablet will
probably work on someone from random
8-inch tablet so the way the system
works if you use these SW qualifies for
your layouts then they'll get picked up
by the kind of the one slightly larger
as well so it's not actually tons and
tons of stuff you do but just by
providing slightly say like you say
bigger touch targets or slightly bigger
font sizes for example unlike a 7-inch
tablet can make a world of difference I
live another another bit of tablet
wisdom is that you know say going back
to the game model you don't have to
necessarily scale up your game to fill
the whole screen you can have a fragment
that that varies its eyes only a certain
amount and then on the larger screens
just put more or less ancillary
information about on the sides of it
yeah indeed we all know that one watch
last night's android phone connection
which covers yeah this is it just the
topic we covered yesterday I'm has a
whole half-hour on it yeah yeah giving a
few techniques you can use to design
around this issue and it it was great
that you guys were looking at the i/o
app which is completely open source so
you can just go in and grab the source
and copy whatever has been done in that
wonderful piece
but you have the new templates in a
android template in use recreate your
project their clips very good deal them
giving this as well and jen has joined
us hello did I ask you a question your
meat it before not talking oh yeah yes
thank you excellent you couldn't hang up
oh well thanks for joining us okay uh
let's jump with expert in the moderator
right then um yeah this this is a yacht
question in the moderator yeah and you
want to ask your question I don't see
okay I wispy lip sync right okay so so
so right right here yawn and the Hangout
has asking is it a good approach to
include in-app purchasing to remove ads
vs. you know within one abk versus
maintaining to applications one with and
one without and I said it's a great idea
to use in application purchasing two to
remove ads and provided this the
developer that Android link for a little
more information I'm you know since
since you can make it a managed to
purchase you can query the server
anytime and find out whether the you
whether that user has purchased the
right to have the whatever unlocked ad
free premium pro version of the app
there's I think there's significant
benefit in not maintaining two different
apks you to a certain extent you're
you're exposing your app potentially to
a little more risk in that you know the
the code that queries the license server
or the in-app purchasing server is
another another attack surface but I
really don't think it opens you
up any more than just having a separate
probe pro version of the APK where
somebody can just you know redistribute
that so I i think that the without
without a lot of extra headaches
involved you can really save yourself
some trouble just by not real not
maintaining two different apks for the
same application and Donald point so
that's that is a first circus especially
it's a smoothie UX so there's not the
jumping out to you know hit I want to go
pro and you had to then install a new
app and it's like wait what now I have
two apps installed I have to own as well
Matt and also any settings or
configuration they may have done gets
carried over cuz it is the same
application they don't have to configure
anything again so that's a lot smoother
and secondly I'd say that all your
reviews and comments will be centralized
in one place and some like a good or bad
thing you couldn't quite often find that
people who've bought a nap will
generally trend higher and your rating
because they paid money for it they tend
to like to justify like to the cells i
think maybe lets his my ID but but yeah
i think having them all in one place is
probably a better thing it's also quite
it present sorry chris go from me no
just I know I mean I did this for
friendcaster I had this before we not
purchasing was even available so i had
two separate ones afraid of pro and i
used to spend a good 10 victims in my
time merging code across because you'd
have to you'd have to do it mon code
base then copy across and what you'd
find is you'd find you wouldn't copy
across correctly you so you have to
spend time fixing layouts and stuff so
in the end or library project other was
that before library project so yeah so
was once lot of projects coming out and
then I can start moving core code into
that and then sharing it but it just it
still took time and so yeah I'd always
go now and what I BK and the other thing
is also is that because it will look for
it could have the free versions your
listing people were more inclined to
download it because it's not a paid app
so and then they can then did he not
purchase where if they want to so
otherwise guy that I know yeah that was
one of the interesting things from IO is
that there was some discussion around
monetizing app and all of the data seem
to point to having
in-app purchases being a better way in a
more consistent way of getting users to
buy your app and it tends to result in
more purchases than trying to get them
to download a separate apk and pay for
that separately justjust devil's
advocate as a slight counterpoint though
I'd say some people just hate your net
purchases you'll see comments in the
market saying you're trying to nickel
nickel and dime me for everything blah
blah blah and some people are just much
happier paying a 1-up price up front I'm
not saying this is many users or most
users so some people just just just
don't like that and the second point is
having a paid app lets you participate
in some kind of like sales and promotion
so for example our recent 25 million
promotion was where we put a bunch of
applications on sale like if you only
had a free application and that wouldn't
have been available to you so not saying
these are great reasons perhaps you
might have both available so you know a
free version with in-app to perhaps
remove the adverts or like a premium
version or whatever that is just like
all in app purchases already included in
a different cost for example for those
people who just really hate it it's up
to you you know depends on who you're
going for what the market is and so on
but yeah I think there's a lot of work
that needs to be done in terms of user
experience on the developer site because
I think it was you Hani point pointed
out an application that basically was a
free application but the moment you ran
it said buy coins and you couldn't do
anything without making an in-app
purchase and that's a straight turnoff
for users it's got to be a bit much
doors it's this one wasn't the only one
that he found what then I guess there
are a few out there but it it has the
Sparky response and people just turn off
straight away so trying to force people
down and in that purchase as the way
around the paid app seems to be more of
a quick way to annoy the user them to
get safe as you think you do and so the
applications that say you get ten moves
and if you send us a couple bucks will
give you another 100 I hate those I hate
those but the apps that say you know you
can you can unlock the first ten levels
of this puzzle game for free and then
you know pay us a couple bucks and will
give you the next hundred levels and you
can you know you can play as much as
little as you like we're not metering
your play we're just giving you access
to the whole thing those I love
yeah I think for me like one of the
coolest ones I've seen is the time Dolph
Vista so like wind-up knight which gives
you lets you play for your first ten
levels or something like that and then
it says hey one-time-only offer unlock
the rest of this game for this one price
we won't be off again kind of thing I
think that kind of taps into the human
psyche of wanting a bargain right like
people okay just one chance to play I
thought that was pretty clever and I
think the developers came on to the show
in the US and said that that one item
yeah was the bulk of their revenue
anything mm-hmm just that they look good
in a store as well okay sorry man so I'm
just gonna say quickly did a good thing
about the in-app billing stuff is if you
make a purchase on one device let alone
market for all your other devices as
well yeah right I hadn't even thought of
that I'm gonna talk about saving your
download trouble yeah you don't
everywhere and you're gonna have the
free install everyone read a story yet
and then you have to go back i'm randall
the new one yeah your plane okay so you
say something's up say they do with the
app store got a car i'm see me but the
app store on iOS you can actually see
what the in-app purchase are you
download something for as I can't
remember that Google Play I quit wrong
but not interesting you can see it needs
the in-app billing permission so your
shows they'll be in a payments in there
somewhere you down odeon see this in app
purchase for play rest of game or
something then you know he's gonna be
dodging my whole of game yeah so there's
a lot of things around that because one
of the things I've seen done in the IR
stories some of the in-app purchases
makes no sense until you start using the
application itself like I think there's
a an application that converts photos
into cartoons and there are things like
the splat in-app purchase and the glam
in that purchase which your kind of
Saturn thinking do I really need to buy
this to put the word blam on screen it's
it it's kind of a double-edged sword
yeah yeah I'm not sure I see the value
than that I could value in it if you
make it cheap enough I mean yeah it
listed below the threshold where I'll
just say oh what the heck for one photo
I'm willing to spend ten cents click no
no I can see the value in a pleasure
zone not I don't see
of a listing them up front when it's
completely out of context okay sorry one
of the ones I quite like is a gem engage
we do so we know who has it adds and
this little X next to it to dismiss them
and that launches in-app purchase which
isn't interesting at all mmm I think
we've done that one to death does anyone
yeah life on the Hangout want to bring
up something of interest to them before
we go back to the moderator or were
there questions in the Google+ stream
that we haven't gotten to yet and
there's one hi then one format in the
comments of the Google+ and got another
question that it's like a live question
yes as it is not a question but a
feature request I like it to include the
feature graphic on you might cut room
bilingual and I say again I miss that
feature a photography uh-huh on my
application by Mike Carter because I to
localize the feature effect yes oh it's
on the end it's on their team's list of
stuff today it is crazy right now right
you can localize all the descriptions
but if you want to localize the great
big graphic that everyone sees and
screenshots and screenshots all that
stuff you have to do multiple listings
and targeting two countries so that
sound it's very very much on the radar
is just when it gets shipped should we
hear you we're here okay and sorry did
you want to go for the question format
in the comments shall I read it yeah go
for it so I am someone's trying to get
their comic app with in-app billing
working on google TV they have the sony
box and I always get stuck at the
billing process authorizing purchase
after 30 seconds is application and
stops responding so I've actually
replied to the stack overflow question
within a blog post come so essentially
there's because we don't support
subscription billing the dungeons and
subscriptions sample doesn't work as is
needs a little bit of tweaking to change
the API version number as well as some
of
the extra variables that you add in so
payment type you don't do that because
otherwise the API starts having some
problems so you need to do that and plus
when I started doing this I had a couple
of issues with just the Google Play
service and making it works i had to
leave it for a little while which I
admit is a bit of a poor thing but I did
actually have one bit of code left it
for a day came back and then it just
started working as I should do I think
it was just propagating with the items
that you're adding to google play and
make sure it works in North indicates
etc so check out the blog post go
through all of that get that working
with your items and then hopefully you
should be able to figure out what's
going on yeah all the standard things
apply don't test it with the same
account you uploaded the app-based aux
you can't buy things from sams there's a
list of five things that you just need
to check when you're testing in our
building in the testimony document yeah
documentation if we get kisi useful so
yes still-still do check that it's just
the the sample just need some
differences which is what my blog post
is focusing on okay and there's a
question in the G+ as well Roberts
asking why in 41 to update for 7-inch
tablets why search bar anchored on the
landscape but an optional in portrait I
none of us him know the answer I'm gonna
speculate hear that it's a UX decision
that in landscape you have so much less
and vegetables face that you don't
really want as many anchored items i'm
going to guess at that being the reason
but i don't know if you're sure i don't
believe it's actually a widget in
landscape mode no it's part of the home
screen right yeah whereas in portrait
mode it's actually a widget that seems
to be used oh is it I only is i think is
popular you can't pick it up or anything
fun Lugo's i'm so confused by this
question is if we're just staring at the
seven tablets could anyone replicate
this so i think it's i don't think is a
widget i think it's part of the whole
thing ice cream out of the launcher yeah
I think so too I i mean i don't think
it's like when you drag a new widget
onto the screen it seems to me like that
search boxes out of the accessible space
can you move it right on yours yeah and
when you drag an icon around
it disappears to make room for the info
and the delete well not only use every
part of the home screen like workspaces
it well I think it's kind of decoration
around it yeah I can't actually drag my
narela just a bit confused when he said
anchored in landscape but optional
import rate yeah I haven't guys convert
I read that as its kind of always there
in portrait but when you go to landscape
you just have the Google now and there
and the voice actions voice search
buttons right right yeah if you have a
vertical textbook exactly that's what
anyway yeah so yeah so basically I'm
saying yeah you wouldn't ever have like
a vertical search box cuz I'd look crazy
I probably wouldn't and so I like
postulate that they didn't want to have
a another reserved area of space in
already limited amount of room when
you're in in landscape will be my guest
okay thanks man I think that's a really
good guess Mike Hanke since it since you
mentioned Google now is this is kind of
a random occurs to me I'm curious to
know who here brings up Google now by
accident more often than on purpose cuz
I know any games interesting come back
to that flight control again making
those little airplanes around the screen
yeah I can suggest one solution if you
have that problem the nexus 7 put it in
a case because it's really hard to bring
it up the tall one sits in a case that
the official google answer that's one of
the downsides of those cheap third-party
cases you get the official asus one and
it leaves you enough screen space to get
the swipe from the problem working mine
was five pounds from i was innocent he
doesn't yeah this was 25 quid from pc
world beer it was pregnant in it though
nope you pay 25 quittin you don't even
get the clothes magnet I've got a smart
cover esque one which like natural flaps
over and stuff it's pretty good soccer
tennis I've got one of those as well
samsung tab what for the for the nexus 7
case yeah i think my next purchase from
amazon is going to be some sellotape and
a magnet
how are we getting on in the word rated
questions yeah have we get one moderator
question I'm just taking a look look 15
is like okay Andre and Czech Republic
wants to know is there a way how to
correctly detected a tablet has a mobile
it's like a friend's 3g interface I need
to hide or display some features based
on that future telephony and
connectivity manager or girl network in
full aren't reliable enough I think I
think I'll had the best answer weapon it
was I was kind of confused because he
thanked featured telephony it can
reliable enough and I was wondering
whether he is already using package
manager has system feature to detect
whether it's on the device I think maybe
he just means is not precise enough
right because there are some features
the clowns at the bottom yet thanks for
your responses but unfortunately there
are some tablets that don't report
feature telephone li as one of the
system features I imagine things like
Wi-Fi only do I fizzy no a galaxy tab 10
1 may have 3g but no telephony because
it doesn't you can't make phone calls
Ryan but the the feature should be edge
says that the device has a telephony
radio with data communication support
which to me would indicate it should be
present if it's just got a data modem on
it it doesn't necessarily need to have a
voice codec as well to handle calls it's
interesting oh yeah I can Trevor if you
could requires telephony in the manifest
whether it would appear for a 3g tab or
not i thought it didn't I don't know but
I i do think maybe there's some
potential in this to telephony manager
get network type which should tell you
like exactly what kind of radio your
your you were talking to at the moment
but but that's what some of them my way
not what's available right Leslie same
query in the sim is a good way to go
Korean similar which which class would
you use to do that Leslie is picking the
side marker on
give him a I'll read up to your arm yeah
yeah you could actually use some tools
libraries to do it we had this problem
in HTC where if you've got a sim that
supports 2gb done support 3g it caused a
bit of confusion we had to actually
query directly I actually see I can find
the HTC devices the custom API that we
used well there is a telephony manager
it gets subscriber ID which is supposed
to return an IMSI number it guess would
i would guess if there's no 3g or no no
telephony component and you wouldn't get
an IMSI back i think you get null back
in that situation is it just an axiom
custom roms that do return imsi or even
fake data just to pass some tests on the
telephony manager so i'll try to do some
try and catch over there come upon their
false data yeah i mean i know we've kind
of had a similar question last week it
comes down to why are you trying to do
that again exactly like it kiss i guess
the main thing you want to do is like
workout do you have a data connection
right which you use get connected he
measured up get active connections is
connected is primo zhang yun 180 chair a
setting which said say it was over and
they wanted to allow calls over 3g you
wouldn't want that setting down at or if
you have 3g device if you do have 3g one
line I took to be there a lot it could
make sense to have a I don't necessarily
use it yeah something users bill said or
else we do x equals 1 I think into the
3g Wi-Fi you only want to show the
option when you have three T as a
natural option yeah but you can send
good really if you're in cellular or if
you're on Wi-Fi just can't tell of this
video to in Fiji yeah I'm if you're only
what you can it continue friesian if you
don't on at the time you start setting
to this side okay what you've gotten one
thing goes yeah the shame competence of
certain OEMs in this
we will allow you to connect to the 3g
night to it but not use it and I won't
mention any names as a driving sale so
what that means is that you might not
have a 3g subscription but it won't
allow you to connect to 3g networks
ain't got 3g but you can't actually send
any data up there's also another issue
which makes the whole thing a bit
unreliable is the use of my fi devices
so if I've got a Wi-Fi tablet and I'm
connecting it to my portable hotspot on
the phone in my pocket if the tablet
thinks it's got a Wi-Fi connection but
the actual end connection is a 3g
cellular on I've that's how I got around
the I players original restriction of
only allowing streaming on Wi-Fi was
just to use a wife mifi device do some
tethering between the tablet and the
mifi device and then you get around any
restriction says although it may be
possible it's not a good thing to rely
on would be my view yeah I can see
whether you'd be nice if those are
coming I would still use fish must be
myself and love and influenza correctly
then so be it but you want to know
whether the even if you've got a sim
card in there you want to know if the
hardware supports that capability and I
would go for the feature telephony it's
going to be the and as suppose of it's a
equality of user experience issue say
maybe you know if you can't pull one
megabit you don't want to offer video or
something like that just do a little
performance test at runtime yeah even
though we could when you're connected
you know what know what you collected on
is just you don't know which networks
are necessarily available to you the
performance test would be the best way
to go definitely because of Wi-Fi
situations like I oh yeah definitely I
think about not making it a setting as
well think about just doing a test and
that you know warning like saying you
know signal strength looks weak you sure
you won't do a video call or whatever
might be right that's what we're just
making it a setting go isn't isn't
always the answer freedom retos blog
post on magic boxes as well what's the
problem with that work in forget subtype
maybe you have to be connected to that
network at the time no no he moving off
it yes sir damn he's using network
campus ftes
have we got any more in the moderator we
do all those dips from andrew kelly in
there andrew kelly yes indeed about you
pay a journalist of page at this android
you and ask yeah since will I've got an
app that i'm writing for a client at the
moment and they've got a list view that
goes into a viewpager kind of mode when
they want to drill down into the details
of the list and so in the list view i
want to show all the items available but
in this or the detail modem in the
viewpager i want to skip over items that
don't have any further details and so
just trying to work out if there's a way
of skipping your the fourth element of
the array without actually having to
create a new array with that fourth
element missing yeah well that's in your
doctor right in the get item method so
yeah so I've got my get count reduce
returns a fewer number of a lower value
based on Pammy rose dat are you get item
still Kipps gets called for the
placeholders that I don't want to the
ones I want to skip over so if I want to
skip over element number four I lovin
you know get item still gets called boys
pass like monotonically increasing
position numbers but I think you're
gonna have to maintain your own mapping
from position to the real item index in
your in your dear just sounds like you
need to get all them you just need to
pay each time to eat a right from the
start and can until you find X number of
items which don't have any flat or do I
infer whatever you don't want yeah I
won't try and avoid the constantly going
looping to the array again and again and
again to work out where was that once
can't you do so the first item is index
1 the second item is index for the third
items in this file yeah maybe you as a
hashmap am and once and then you'll have
all the indexes need two items with the
details and then when you use the get
item then you'll just need to verify
that you have the index
in your apartment I'm sorry well you can
even if you put it put it into a hashmap
you could then get the entry setback and
iterate over the entry set yeah it
suggests yeah it's good idea yeah just
run through ones are we talking about an
enormous list here though this is
something you need to be real a doubt
you know 20 at most so you know I just
run through the biggest free throws here
is there the possibility for some of the
items to change so good item number to
be populated and then later down the
line item to not be populated and not
without going all the way back out and
then all the way back in through the
original kind of summary list but I take
the hit and do it once precious at once
and then have this kind of hash map
cause I think yeah knows yes crane
arrives me yeah well I thought it might
be a handy sort of is enabled kind of
true or false kind of method I could
just call for the ones that I want to
skip over no I mean you have full
control your adapter it wouldn't ask the
adapter then ignore it self-service
sorry what's up or you could extend
viewpager make your own implementation
that your enlightened view pager yeah
you said that item sent it yeah I the
reason I appointed to the Sherlock demo
that's that's out there I'm code google
com is because the the viewpager
implementation on that little sample app
basically it you know although view
pager is sequential it basically just
pokes a random access value into the tab
manager and because it's it smashing of
view pager and tabs together and so it's
kind of a way to to jump from your
sequential access of the viewpager into
the random access and all you have to do
is intervene at that point to tell it
which which you know page or tab to show
yeah you could do it so that when you go
to item number for auto scroll down he'd
scroll 24 and then it would ultimately
just move on which because it's an empty
item best years would know they've gone
past item for this page is intentionally
left blank something no but i think but
anything I would that be fun
five miss Kay we've squeezed in the last
how many forgot left in the moderator
Sparky to get in the next former it's
one more for more informative go go
ahead and the source code can i find the
4.1 lock screen google it you ready
buddy i read all so that the
developer.android.com documentation as
part of 80 s p i assume so it's I mean
we put the AOSP copyright in our in our
sample code and stuff it is i'll put a
link to the location in the knife yeah
and i think the lock screens is called
the keyguard so if you if he crept coach
it keyguard i think is the thing you're
looking for sounds right to me plus one
next next method can i retrieve data
from Google Maps API so that i can use
it for my location-based service yes use
the Google Maps API developers
google.com / Maps next muffin I have a
device with only Ethernet connection how
can I find if device is really connected
to the network try to push some traffic
thrills 59k do get active network is
connected next try connect to Google's
web page that is good news connected
will do that right it's connected is
like the blue you know how your Wi-Fi
turned blue in it there's really bits
flowing i'm pretty sure it's based on
the same logic and this does this sort
of code features prominently i believe
in retos blog article about writing
battery friendly apps so yeah you can
use search word on developer.android.com
we've got blog articles and google i/o
talks that all touch on this is anybody
aware of how android handles daylight
savings time changes it does also even
if an even if it didn't I I mean
generally speaking you want your device
to get its time of day from either your
phone network or or ntp in wit and in
either of those cases you know they're
smart to not smart enough to know about
daylight savings time
and when it happens then it your device
will notice that it's out of sync and
it'll reset itself but they are also
asking which part of the source code
deals with this is that they want to get
some pull something out and reuse maybe
I think that same is hard yeah I think
neff actually handled by a lot of the
lower level linux stuff that's
underneath Android I wouldn't be too
surprised java deals with a pretty yeah
maybe no java joe's it horribly look
here look at like Joe your time or
something that perhaps don't you show
time its massive remember in the run-up
to jelly bean for a little while we
actually had a bug where the MTP
fallback wasn't working right remember
so Android actually has a utility class
which reimplement and the getting the
number of milliseconds from the epoch
because it's so unreliable in certain
parts of Java so ok yeah what's that in
systems I'll get current melis or the
time is meaning there's a I can dig out
the method but there's actually an
android version of system don't get
current time in Millie's which is used
for key events and you can pick that out
and bassy does the same thing but I'm
guessing it's there because there's some
discrepancies about how it gets reported
through it was an interesting us but I
wrote about the three or four different
tough way you can get their current time
I think the most accurate one was the
one from the kernel which is exposed up
for a native pin that you India trying
to get out come with that are we done
should we I don't that's it for the
moderator tablets it also takes up a
tent I'm screwed in setting off the line
that's people do speaking some any any
last last minute questions from from the
Hangout yeah just a question about the
subscription and trial birth parents yes
if I want to do an appt 12 for a trial
period but it's not a system basically a
subscription
alps say you want to do it like a snooze
button or a silent button widget and
instead of doing it into a paid app or
something like that can I operate on a
trial version with some sorts of special
night the only thing if you're not using
subscriptions the only option would be
to do in a billing and then pop up a
dialogue after 30 days or however long
you want a diff reappear get to be
subscriptions is the only part of the
Google Play that offers a free trial
period for you and for that free trial
you have to sign up to the subscription
you have to have the valid payment
details in place be the first book cycle
complete it will start on you yeah cool
right I think that's all we hit I wanna
see more hundreds on my own or offices
we talked about close up with the tour
of the EBU office there's an apple yeah
it's a debating room you know
everybody's fighting so we're doing some
hold office dude thank you all very much
for joining us today uh we will be back
again next week bigger yep so hopefully
maybe see some people watching in def
fest berlin this weekend Matt you're
gonna be in Paris tomorrow speaking to
the wonderful pork Harris on Friday yep
Berlin or tarde I don't forget this a
great shows on Friday there's the app
clinic in the Friday games review and
join us next tuesday Android design in
action or see you all next week next
Wednesday hopefully for more office eyes
and they're traitors one breath attempt
to read everything that's going on in
turn in the way I swear last week he was
offering badges haha I by